Procedure for regularizing a sick foreigner
what are the
conditions to be fulfilled in order to initiate such a procedure ?
What are the steps to follow?
What documents should be provided?
Dear friends,
hello,
Welcome to my advice channel,
of exchange and legal expertise.
I am Amélie and I am a lawyer.
Subscribe if you haven't already,
in the favorites.
Don't hesitate to ask questions.
If you are a foreigner,
you reside in France,
do you want to be regularized for reasons
of disease?
You must meet these 2 conditions.
The foreigner
must therefore be sick and unable to
access to health care
adapted to his pathology
in his country of origin to.
Pathology that affects
the health of the foreigner
requires 1 immediate care
to such an extent that the non-immediate care
from abroad could have consequences
extremely serious about his health.
So what are the steps to follow
and at every step
what document
are necessary?
1st step is to make an appointment at the prefecture.
1 time the appointment obtained,
go to the prefecture,
therefore to his appointment
with a document
identity or proof of identity
established by 1 competent authority
from your country of origin.
It can be your passport,
of your card
of your country,
of your license if the driver's license is
is considered as 1 piece of identity in your country
the day of your appointment at the prefecture,
after a few oral questions and verification.
Your identity,
the prefecture will give you
1 living room kit that is nothing else
than an envelope
containing 2 documents.
1st document,
1 medical certificate to be completed by your doctor
and in the envelope is also,
say 1 notice
explanatory.
You will take these certificates,
present them to your physician (s)
that will therefore fill them,
sign them and you too sign.
Then you bring
this certificate in the envelope to loshi,
French Office of Immigration and Integration.
It is 1 doctor of loshi or 1 doctor of doctor
who will review your application in the first instance.
This doctor will give 1 opinion
to the prophetess
and it is only from this moment
that the prophet will make 1 decision.
When you go to the aufi,
don't forget
provide all justifications
related to your pathology,
blood test,
all you had to do about your
disease.
Attention it is very important,
this is the most important step
important because it is
combined examination of all these elements that loshi
will be able to give 1 opinion
regarding your application.
So your regularization for disease depends on it,
that's why it's important.
It is the need to include elements in the file
essential to request
for your pathology,
not newspaper clippings
of your country's health policies,
no.
But all you have to do is wait
the decision of the prefecture